tout à l'heure on a parlé du du problème
sanitaire il a bon dos le problème
sanitaire
non seulement on prend des décisions
sans tenir compte des instances
démocratiques
bientôt il y aura plus d'élection
départementales et régionales parce que
ça va arranger l'exécutif
maintenant on a même des textes parce
qu'il ya quand même des présidentielles
en 2022 et je suis pas tout à fait
innocent au point de penser que le
président de la république qui va pas ça
en tête peut-être une
instrumentalisation du coup du contexte
sanitaire pour vous pour ne pas avoir
les élections de 2021
je parle pas d'instrumentalisation je
pense simplement qu'il ya des élections
le président malgache cette tanière pour
vous au mois de mars prochain
le président de la république il pense à
l'élection du président de la république
pas lui en vouloir
on peut dire que ses prédécesseurs ont
fait la même chose donc qu'est-ce qui
fait il se dit qu'est ce qui est bon
pour préparer les élections
présidentielles tête c'est pas
indispensable d'avoir les élections
régionales et départementales parce que
mes copains ils sont pas tellement
préparés à ce genre d'élection c'est pas
bon et puis pour moi c'est peut-être
mieux si j'ai ce genre de texte pour
préparer 2022
c'est comme ça c'est le canard